is war in general apart
of the fundamental ideas that socialists
are again Democratic socialists are
against like what's the relation between
socialism and War so I think that
traditionally in the Socialist movement
war was associated with
um capitalist competition and
international competition and you can
look at World War one is very much a
case where different nations were
competing with each other and developing
quite uh violent rivalries that was in
part based on competition and the
periphery over access to markets and
colonies and and whatever else so it was
very easy to draw a direct correlation
um
I am opposed to
to more
um I'm opposed to imperialism the
domination of strong Nations you know
dominating
um smaller Nations
um I wouldn't call myself a pacifist I
think most socialists wouldn't call
themselves pacifists because there are
some struggles that are worth fighting
for you know there's National Liberation
struggles and so on where if there's no
Democratic Avenue for for change you
know positive change has been made
through through armed revolts around
colonialism and whatnot but we're living
in an age where hopefully
um you know I know neither of us have
children but are our children or
children children you know in the future
won't have to live through war and that
is one thing that as uh countries have
gotten more developed
um as the world has changed we've
actually seen less and less war like I
won't dispute Pinker on on this I think
it's true
um obviously Putin's invasion of Ukraine
and you know the conflict in Ethiopia is
like kind of an exception but on the on
the whole I think we're we're going in
that in that uh Direction but I think
it's always been you know a major
organizing plank of socialists uh
against the war and against just kind of
this sense of
right-wing nationalism and national
identity that often leads to war and
obviously not everyone on the right has
embraced that a lot of Libertarians are
consistently anti-war as well but I
think the right ideologically has been
associated with war even if some
Advocates of capitalism have not been
then there's the military industrial
complex which is the financial machine
of the whole thing I I presume
well well since a lot of that is
government what's the relationship to
socialism and the military industrial
complex
well a lot of it's government contracts
but it's privately produced right by
companies like Lockheed Martin and
things like that
um you could draw a very crude
materialist connection between any of
these things and to kind of prove an
ideological point but we could produce
just as many arms and then just bury
them or never fire them off or whatever
whatever else obviously there are
companies that have a vested interest in
um heightening up tensions or saying
that we need to buy a new weapon system
to be prepared for a conventional war
with China Russia uh meanwhile I think
we all know that if there's going to be
conventional war between these countries
like it's gonna
you know it's going to lead to something
worse
um and and you know no amount of
advanced fighter jets is going to make a
make a difference
um but I try to avoid crude or causal
connections even though there are
relationships like it's kind of like
um the old slogan which was quite an
effective slogan in the early 2000s at
my my first anti-war marches when I was
a teenager I definitely have shouted it
but kind of no war for oil like both is
like correct in that it gets to what
people's senses of like what's going on
how it's bad but also like analytically
it's kind of wanting to explain what
really happened or why we ended up in
the you know in the Middle East which is
like a much more complex geopolitical
story
yeah and it is a story of geopolitics
it's perhaps less a story of capitalism
or socialism it's a story
um yeah it's a geopolitical story that I
think actually operates outside of the
economic system of individual Nations it
has to do more with
honestly in part egos of leaders
um and there's a international battle
for resources
but surely there's alternatives
yeah definitely and I think that part of
what being a socialist is is about
dreaming in the long term about a
different sort of world without in my
mind needless divisions of people into
nations with standing armies you know
I'm sure we'll still have pride about
where we're from and there's still be a
distinctive cultural features and so on
about where we're from uh we definitely
would at least for the foreseeable
future be divided into
um places as like administrative units
but the idea that there should be a
Mexican Army and an American Army and a
Russian army and a Ukrainian Army is
just on the face of it I think in the
long run will be seen as ridiculous just
like we see it as ridiculous today
looking back at the idea that you know
um
a um Lord from London would you know be
engaged in civil Strife with the Lord
from like Liverpool and a bunch of
peasants will die would die you know
just kind of on the face of it just
seems kind of ridiculous these different
places would have their own banners and
Lords and armies I think in the long run
you might have to zoom out a thousand
years but in the long run people will
say the same about nation states and
standing armies and battles over you
know specks of of dirt that mean nothing
in a cosmic sense
yeah I know for sure aliens would laugh
at us or humans that go far beyond Earth
and look at the history
hmm well most of the history will be
forgotten
because if humans successfully expand
out into the universe just the scale of
civilization will grow so fast that the
the bickering of the first few thousand
years of human history will be seeming
significant there's a very Marxist idea
that I both appreciate in one way but on
the other hand it's kind of scary which
is that you know um human history is
only now beginning before we're in
prehistory yeah but in the future like
we'll be in kind of real history
um you know I think that that a lot of
really important history has already
happened and and um and I think
posterity will will remember and I think
that it will be easier to sign
um you know certain people the role of
like villains the people
um you know not to engage in the
contentious topic off topic of Ukraine
or whatever else but the idea that you
know one government or man would launch
a you know War to recover you know um or
to take you you know several hundred
square miles of territory and tens of
thousands of people die I think seems
absurd to us many people today luckily
but it would not have seemed absurd 50
60 years ago it would have just been a
normal thing right this kind of
territorial disputes and so on and I
think you know projecting in the future
I think within our lifetimes we'll live
to see
um that kind of conflict be uh
eradicated and in part you could say
that
like why I think it's because of popular
pressure and organization so you could
say kind of the pro worker socialist
organizing part of it making it less
normal if you're a capitalist you could
say uh well markets are more interlinked
so war is even more irrational
um I don't really have a firm answer or
whatever it is I think it's a good thing